my name is Rob Simmons and I'm a
independent computer science educator
and curriculum designer in Raleigh North
Carolina and I'm talking today about an
idea called contracts and using
contracts for getting more programs less
wrong just so you know in advance I'm
not really expecting that I'll have a
lot of time for questions but if I do
I'll take them from solidia or slide oh
or Zelda or whatever it's called and so
the inspiration for this talk comes in
many ways from Gary Bernhardt's 2015
talk call strings loop called ideology
and I want to start by talking about two
of the ideas that he presented in that
talk and I'm calling these two ideas the
leap and the gap so the example that
I've modified a little bit from his talk
is the notion of a function hue that
takes a red green blue value and returns
a floating-point value in the range
between 0 and 365 that represents the
RGB values hue y0 to 365 because hue is
a measure of degree in a polar
coordinate system which I didn't know
before I wrote this talk maybe you did
but I think that's cool anyway a red
green blue value in this setting is
going to be a tuple of 3 floating point
values which we're going to treat is
between being between 0 & 1
that's our example we're not going to
talk about implementing this function I
just want you to think about what we
would mean to specify this function and
to test it well we want some examples so
you've got a green and a blue and a nice
dark yellow and we would want to make
sure in our test cases that these inputs
to the function all actually produce the
desired output so we would specify that
here and at this point we make what I'm
calling the leap from our very small
number of tests we're going to make a
leap of intuition or a reason or faith
that our code is actually going to work
right on the entire world of reasonable
inputs that we might give to our
function based on a small number of test
cases we assume that will always behave
correctly and even if you write
thousands of test cases for this kind of
example you're effectively testing zero
percent of the input space and also this
doesn't handle the realities of being in
Ruby or JavaScript or Python or what not
because we've also got to deal not just
with the reasonable input but we've got
to deal with ok what happens if I pass a
null to this function what's it going to
do in that case this probably needs to
be a test case so we specify this
behavior and like what happens if I
what's the hue of 33 like you know most
dynamic type systems are going to allow
this input and we have to think about
this ahead of time Reds a color so do we
need to give the hue of this color like
no probably not
but if we don't think ahead of time of
what we're going to do here then we're
going to be in trouble later on here's a
another example of how we might be in
trouble later on if we only index this
tuple by indices then we would probably
silently except for floating-point
numbers instead of 3 and then we're in a
situation where ok this is going to be a
backward compatibility nightwear because
someone's going to depend on this
behavior and if we change it we're going
to break someone's code even though it
was outside of the specification of our
function as we understood it and then we
have even like more cantankerous
examples where we have three
floating-point numbers just like we
asked for but they're outside the range
of 0 to 1 inclusive so the idea here is
that we can't just write tests thinking
about the reasonable inputs we also have
to write tests thinking about the entire
world of unreasonable inputs that we
might have to consider which is a huge
multi-dimensional space that was by
definition things that we didn't want to
think about but if we don't think about
this ahead of time someone's going to
rely on it and and so this idea this is
what I'm calling the gap this is the gap
between our specification
and what we actually are allowed to pass
the function what the compiler allows
the function to get for dynamic types
this gap is traditionally pretty big
that's how dynamic type systems work
maybe we're working in something like
you know a Java or a C and at least at
that point we don't have to worry about
getting a string where we asked for
three floating-point numbers we still
have to deal with the original sin of C
and Java style languages which is the
null pointer exception and so then we
think I know how to deal with this one I
just go to Haskell or standard ml or
whatnot and then that those type systems
have ways of excluding null pointers and
maybe you have some idea about
technology that we could use to get rid
of these last two examples where we have
an out of range value but if you don't
have any idea about that that's fine
let's just go on because what I want to
talk about is in the languages that we
deal with there's basically always going
to be this leap this leap between the
tests that we wrote and the idea of
correctness on our spec and there's also
going to be and there's also going to be
a gap a gap between the specification of
our input and the and the inputs that
were allowed to give by the type system
this gap may be big this gap may be
small but there's pretty much always
going to be a gap and so it's in this
context that I'm going to talk about
contracts as ways of solving this leap
and this gap or dealing with this and
I'm going to talk about the gap first as
an example here I'm going to make a
silly example that illustrates a
terrifyingly real problem we've got some
function that does some crypto stuff I
don't know what it does but it may be
easy to imagine that we need this
cryptography function to be given a very
large prime number in order to work
correctly and it's probably easy to
imagine that such a function could
appear to work if you gave it a small or
non prime number but would do something
bad or insecure or violate your privacy
or allow your
to be leaked to you know Facebook or
whatnot and and so if you see this kind
of comment in code you should be
absolutely terrified because you're
counting on the consumers of your code
looking into whatever file you wrote
this function in and wherever you wrote
this comment and noticing that you had
this requirement on your code this is
really a big problem so let's solve that
problem by adding a star to our comment
which gives us a use of the magic
comments anti-pattern where we recognize
this as a Java doc syntax which means
that this constraint on X is now going
to be treated as a part of the
specification of the function and at
least exported from where we wrote the
function out into the world contracts in
this sense are just an extension of this
idea where instead of writing English
constraints on X we write a boolean
condition as a precondition to our
function that talks about X this says
slash wash out requires which is a use
of the magic comments anti pattern that
recognizes this comma as either the Java
modeling language or C not an
educational programming language which
I'll talk about later and this
precondition is about as intelligible as
the previous comment was but it's also
possible as a boolean condition by by
the computer we also needed the X to be
Prime we could express a weaker
condition like hopefully so please don't
be even but if we have a primarily test
test lying around which we might if
we're doing cryptography of some sort
then we could just say oh I need this to
be Prime and maybe you have some idea
about technology that could enforce
these kinds of conditions in the
compiler but maybe you don't and that's
fine too because the idea with contracts
is just to run these things when we're
in debug mode so if we try to call
crypto stuff with a million and one
which is not prime I checked don't ask
me what the factors are then we'll get a
runtime failure in our
that says that the precondition number
to failed because I checked whether it
was prime and I found out that it wasn't
and so that's bad in your bad and should
feel bad and if we give it a small prime
number then we're going to get
information that we failed the
precondition and the reason that this is
really great more than just sort of
writing unit tests is that we can then
later on be writing debug mode where
we've got some poorly thought through
encryption and we're trying to do
something to the string strange loop and
deep inside of our call stack we have
unbeknownst to us violated the
precondition for crypto stuff meaning
that something is insecure or you know
or not private and we will because of
the contracts being run at runtime in
the bug mode get not just a notion that
something went wrong with crypto stuff
but potentially a stack trace which I've
cropped intentionally because I don't
know what this code is to to give us the
ability to find where this precondition
violation actually happened in the code
another example of how this use of
contracts can really help us as
developers is if we have the execution
of some program and it's going along
great and we're really happy and oh no
there was a null pointer exception or we
can't read field B of undefined and I
hate it when this happens because the
call stack isn't even going to help us
we have to trace the data dependency
back through our code and we have to
trace the data pendency back through our
code and we have to and you know this
code may even be written by by somebody
else and so we've got to deal with that
and so like we can't change this orange
code so we're gonna end up putting a
defensive check at this point in the
code and this is may be helpful at first
but the notion of what even is someone
else's code really does change over time
so as you develop your project what you
end up seeing is you've get these
defensive checks everywhere in your call
stack and these are really bad because
they confuse what's actual program logic
and what is you know you have this
intermingled notion of here's what's
program logic
and here's the code that I actually want
to to be defensive to explain what I'm
doing contracts are very helpful in this
situation animation fail because we can
because we can turn all of our contracts
off and run in production code because
we had a uniform language supported
mechanism for explaining what these
preconditions are and then we can also
run in debug mode where we're where
we've turned all of these defensive
checks back on so not only are our
contracts a useful part of our
documentation our contracts are able to
be executed and implemented at runtime
if we wish but there's still clear clear
separation of what's program logic and
what's code Oh what's program logic and
what's specification so this is the
first takeaway that I want you to get
from this talk contracts fill a gap
between what the types enforce will be
input to your function and what the
actual input specification is it's a
language level support mechanism that
allows us to both document for humans
and enforce with computers the
preconditions to our function at this
point I want to move from talking about
the gap and talking about preconditions
to talking about this conceptual leap
from tests to full correctness and
talking about that in terms of post
conditions again I'm going to create a
new test this is a simple test we're
doing search for an int in an array
that's not sorted this is a nice example
for this because there's no gap we can
treat this as any input is going to be
that's allowed by the type system is
like okay for an integer search function
and if we start with that assumption
well we're going to write some tests
because that's what we do and what we're
gonna say is this should return the
index where the integer is found so if 3
is an index 0 returns 0 if 3 is the 0 1
2 3 fourth thing in the array we're
going to return 3
and then we also need some tests where
we don't find three anywhere in the
array and the standard thing to do in
these situations seems to be to return
negative one so again at this point
we're going to make that conceptual leap
to saying we've written our code we've
tested our function and now we believe
or at least we sure hope that this works
correctly
on all reasonable inputs but this is
pretty scary because probably the array
index that we're returning is going to
be immediately used to index a different
array so we would really like to know a
little bit more than our test cases
provided that we actually produced a
valid array index and we can write
another contract this is an insurer's or
post condition contract that says
alright the result needs to be a valid
array index oh wait or it can be
negative one all right this is better
this contract tells us that that the
result that we returned has to be
between negative 1 and if it's not
negative 1 it has to be a valid array
index this is say this post condition is
expressing the notion that the range the
valid outputs of our function are
dependent on a property of the data we
put into the function and maybe you have
some idea about how this could be
enforced by the compiler but maybe you
don't and that's fine because we can
just run this at runtime and make sure
that we never give an out-of-balance
array index from our search function
this is a pretty lightweight test we
could actually do a lot more and we
could test full correctness of our
search function full correctness of the
search function means that we only
return negative one if X was not
actually anywhere we only want to say we
didn't find it if it wasn't there and
also if we return an array index that
should be really B where the thing was
or else we have a clearly broken search
this will be the one time in the talk
where I say you don't necessarily need
to read this code but I'm going to flash
it up to say that yes we can enforce
these English post conditions as
contracts and at this point this is a
complete specification
search in a for an integer in an array
any function that satisfies this post
condition is a valid search unless it
changes the array which would be really
bad okay now this is a complete
specification of what it means to be a
search function and any satisfying
program is going or any setting that
satisfies this post condition is a
correct search function so at this point
I'm going to accuse us all of a grave
sin most of the time we don't actually
care about this picture where we really
want to know that from our test cases we
give the right thing on all outputs or
all inputs we don't care about all
inputs we just care about all the inputs
that we're ever going to get if we don't
get caught that's great and and and this
is where this notion of post condition
testing comes up it is really useful
because another way that we express the
truth that I'm saying here is that we
want to make sure that we test our
function on realistic inputs and you
know what's a good way to generate
realistic inputs the rest of your
program and so with contracts enabled
every single test that we write that
depends on fine also is a test of find
so the takeaway here is that contracts
can act as a double check on the results
of every single function call contracts
in this way make tests way more awesome
and we want tests to be more awesome
because it's really hard to write tests
so the tests that we write we should get
as much mileage out of as we possibly
can so that's the story about how
contracts help us address this gap
between what the type system gives us as
input and what we actually want is input
and this conceptual leap from our test
of full correctness this is a story
that's about jml and I do want to
briefly talk about a different story
this other story is about another line
of work on contract
so contracts are a fundamental idea
that's been explored a lot in
object-oriented languages that's the jml
idea but they've also been explored in
functional languages especially the
scheme and racket realms of the universe
and contracts as I described them in jml
are used as documentation and for
testing there's this emphasis of making
sure that they're very very expressive
so that they can narrow this leap and
this gap as much as possible and we
don't you know if it's not efficient
then maybe we don't care as much about
that because we're only doing this in
debug mode and functional languages
there's been a really cool research that
I wish I had more time to talk about
about using contracts to check interface
boundaries between different type
systems between different ways of
checking your code at the compile time
that have different static guarantees
and when you're doing that the the
contracts look a little bit more typey
than our contracts have they look more
like types and also we better be able to
run those suckers fast because they are
always on because the type system safety
guarantees are dependent on the
contracts and the you know and obviously
in jml we've talked we don't want these
contracts always to be on for double
checking or fine function that's like we
should get fired like on prod and also
functions are values and functional
languages I wish I could talk more about
this but there's a lot of research and
making the fact that you're passing
functions with contracts to functions
like that's cool and I won't be talking
about it and the reason is what I want
to talk about is another line of work
in the Java world which is not just
checking interface boundaries by using
contracts but checking the internal
properties of code and thinking about
that codes correctness using contracts
you'll notice there are two asterisks
here and the asterisks are because
closure exists and I'm not going to talk
more about closure but talk to me later
I at this point want to talk more about
this interesting idea that we could use
contracts not just to enforce boundaries
but to enforce internal properties of
code
this is where I think this gets really
cool but full disclosure I'm an enormous
nerd so the reason this gets cool is so
far we've treated contracts like they're
this black box or we treated used
contracts like functions or a black box
if we want to open up the guts of those
functions and think not just about the
input conditions and the output
conditions but their inner workings what
we end up needing are ways of talking
about the invariants the invariance of
our data structures and the invariance
of our control structures in particular
the invariance of our loops I'm going to
talk more about loop invariants because
it basically lets me give you a tiny
taste of the way that we present this
material to undergraduates at Carnegie
Mellon's principles of imperative
programming course where which I had
previously taught at for three or four
years so with that let me say there okay
we are now looking at a typescript
interpreter for the seanut language the
after mentioned programming language and
come on give me my mouse there we go
this is an implementation of the
Fibonacci function in this in this
interpreter you'll notice it's a it's a
naive functional implementation of the
of the Fibonacci function and we know
that because we've got it makes two
recursive calls it says if n is greater
than 1 then the Fibonacci number is the
Fibonacci number two steps back plus the
Fibonacci number of one step back and
this is a hilariously inefficient way of
calculating Fibonacci so we can do
Fibonacci
four and Fibonacci of 5 and Fibonacci of
six
oh that was a four again six okay and
yeah so we have a three five eight this
is the pattern that we expect from the
Fibonacci but it's hilariously
inefficient if I type
30 then there's going to be a really
noticeable delay and if I type fib 40
there's going to be an even more
noticeable delay because this is
exponential in the size of the input and
so I luckily have not crashed my laptop
for the strange loop demo and so what I
want now is let's write a faster
Fibonacci function and the way that
we're going to write a fib enough Esther
Fibonacci function you may vaguely
remember this but first we're going to
say that the specification of this
function can be written using contracts
so we're going to require that the that
in is greater than or equal to 1 y
greater than or equal to 1 it solves a
problem later bonus points if you catch
it and we're going to have as our post
condition that the result is equal to
the thing that the inefficient version
would give so this is a common pattern
you write the clear mathematical
definition and then you use that to
validate the hopefully faster maybe a
little bit more complexity so there's a
pretty standard technique for using for
implementing the Fibonacci function in
this way and you probably remember the
general outlines but if not work through
you you need to keep both the current
value in the previous values so let's
say aunt old and in new and then we're
gonna have some for loop with I is the
loop variable we're going to return new
and inside of this loop what we're going
to do is we're going to create the next
value which is old plus new and then
we're going to use that to update the
values so old gets new and new gets next
and so this is what we you know this is
the the general structure of how we
write the Fibonacci function and let's
be honest with each other if you were
just doing this what you would do at
this point is you would write in some
constants you would see if you are off
by 2
or zero in which direction and then you
would adjust your constants until you
had what seemed to be a correct
implementation let's use contracts and
see if we can do a little bit better
than that so the way that we're gonna do
a little bit so let's you know as a
first part we're gonna say that old is
gonna be fib of 0 and new is going to be
fib of 1
these aren't these aren't contracts and
just like keeping track of what I'm
doing Bob
and at this point the next thing that
I'm going to write is a loop invariant a
loop invariant is a contract that's
going to be checked before every
iteration of the loop including before
the first iteration of the loop and it's
going to be checked after every
iteration of the loop including after
the last iteration of the loop and the
loop invariant expresses what we think
is always true about our loop and
intuitively what we're doing here is
because we're returning new we want to
be treating invariant we want to be
treating new as fib of I the current
index and we want to enforce the the old
as the trailing value so we want to say
loop invariant old equals fib of I minus
one so this says as a loop invariant
that new is the leading value and old as
the trailing value which was kind of the
intuition that we express and if we
think just about the beginning of our
loop this tells us how we need to
initialize I because in order for new to
initially be fib of I new is fib of 1 or
new is 1 so he need I to initially be 1
so because we set new to initially be
fib of 1 we need I to initially be 1
that's the first constant that we
definitely would have gotten wrong if
we'd done this just by trying to guess
in check and we did it just by trying to
say ok like what are the loop invariants
that were
gonna want to maintain and then from
that that told us exactly how we needed
to initialize the loop variable now
rather than thinking about the inside of
the loop I want to switch immediately to
thinking about after the loop and after
the loop we're going to we're going to
be returning new if we return new what
does it mean for that to be the right
answer well we want asserts another
contract we want new to equal fib of n
because that assertion is exactly the
post condition of the function where
we've substituted the result placeholder
for new which is the thing that we
return so if we want new to be equal to
fib of n well you may have some
intuition for how to actually set the
loop guard in order to do this we're
going to set the loop guard to be I less
than in and the reason that we're going
to do this is we need to show that I is
equal to n we need to show that I is
equal to n because if we know that I is
equal to n after the loop is finished
then we can use the second the last loop
invariant and substitute I for N and
then we have the assertion so
substitution from the loop invariant
gives us the assertion substitution from
the assertion gives us the post
condition and we're done if we set I to
be if we set the loop guard to be I is
less than n then we know after the
function terminates that we know that I
is that it's not the case that I is less
than in the loop exited so the loop
guard must be false and if the loop
guard is false that means that I is
greater than or equal to N and if I is
greater than or equal to n and we need
to know that I is equal to n then the
missing piece of this information is
that that I is less than or equal to N
and how do we know that I is less than
or equal to n well that
another loop-invariant obviously in our
loop were always going to keep i within
the range between one and n so we write
that as a loop invariant that one is
less than or equal to i and is less than
or equal to n and this gives us all the
power we need to reason about our
function remember at this point that the
loop invariant is checked after the last
iteration of the loop so if i'd tried to
make this strict then I would go over
here and I'd try to run fib of 3 and I'd
get a loop invariant failure because my
loop invariant when I was about to exit
the loop would necessarily fail so what
I want to do is fix that code and here
is going to be the moment of truth where
I can run with contracts on fib 4 and
fib 5 and okay based on our private
prior discussion if fib of 6 works then
we're just going to believe this is
correct all the time and ok good so this
is correct all the time this is of
course with contracts on a terrible
algorithm because we're now running the
inefficient version of our growth room
in a loop inside of our efficient
algorithm so like fib of 30 doesn't even
work anymore this is ok good it didn't
crash my laptop and and so with what
I've just shown you with this algorithm
is a very quick picture of how we do two
steps of three steps of reasoning so
we've shown logically that from the
preconditions and initializations I do
the loop invariant will initially hold
true we've also shown that from our loop
convergent I can reason logically about
the post condition of our function being
true there's one step that's still
missing which is that we need to show
that the loop invariant actually like
you know is a loop invariant and the way
that we walk through this is again I
think really fun
but as I've already said I'm a huge nerd
this is the loop a little bit more
close-up and what we're going to do in
order to think about how this make sure
this loop invariant is actually
preserved over an iteration of the loop
is a process that's called symbolic
evaluation which are scary words but all
you need to think about is that imagine
you're waking up naive an innocent to
the world in the middle of a loop and
you don't have any idea how many times
that this is run before oh this is
basically the good place and spoilers
the and so all you know is that the loop
invariants hold and so we've got old and
new and we know what the values are I
mean we don't know what the values are
but we kind of know what the values are
we know old contains fib of I minus 1
and we know new contains fib of AI and
then the first thing we do is we say
that next gets old plus new which we
also know as fib of I minus 1 plus fib
of AI which we also know as the next
Fibonacci number right so ok great
now think about what's gonna happen on
the next step of the next line of code
I'm gonna overwrite the value in old
with the value in new all right and then
I'm going to override the value in new
with the value in next and I hope you
follow that then the next step okay
what's going to happen here because for
loops are weird so we go back up to the
top of and the next thing we're going to
do is our loop increment and at that
point we're gonna first take next out of
scope and I'm going to admit here I'm
skipping a couple of steps that we do
with the undergraduates but what's
actually happening is because we're
increasing I the value fib of I is now
going to be fib of I minus 1 and having
executed this loop increment again
asking you to trust me a little bit
we're going to we can observe that we're
done with the loop and
loop-invariant is restored because old
still contains fib of I minus one and
new still contains four bhai even though
all of those values have changed this is
again a quick picture of how we've done
a complete partial correctness proof of
this Fibonacci function we've shown that
the precondition implies the loop
invariant that the loop invariant is
preserved that the loop invariant
implies the post condition logically we
haven't shown that the function
terminates but of course it does and
with more than 10 minutes to explain
this this is a kind of reasoning that
we've successfully managed to teach to
college freshmen and you know what we
can teach to if we can teach something
to college freshmen it turns out that
nowadays we can often teach that to
computers you know and and I and so this
kind of reasoning that I've just
performed is not only teachable as an
educational project but it's teachable
to a computer that can check these
proofs and make sure that the reasoning
that we've done about contracts is
always correct
I will admit it's not fun now the
college freshmen are fun I love teaching
college freshmen but but working with
the current theorem proven technology is
not and contracts it's not that much fun
for the systems I've used like run time
contracts are fun using their
improvements to prove contracts correct
it's it's not fun but I am convinced
that fun in this instance is an
engineering problem and so I believe
we'll get there that's the last takeaway
that I wanted to give you so contracts
in addition to being about interfaces
are a scaffold for reasoning about
programs and if we go through this you
know not easy but doable process of
proving contracts correct then we've got
compile time guarantees that can depend
on the specific values our program sees
at run time and if you've been scared by
all the subliminal messages I've been
giving you this whole talk
don't be you've now seemed dependent
types if you prove contracts correct
then you have compiled time guarantees
that depend on the specific value is
your program will see at run time go to
the little typer release party this
evening be enlightened it's it's good
and so that's the that's the third
takeaway I see that I am over time so
I'm going to skip the last conversation
there's a link on my website about Tim
sword which is a fundamental sorting
algorithm in every commander dry brer II
and how we a bunch of people that work
with the key theorem prover use Tim sort
tried to prove it correct had trouble
that was because there was a bug they
fixed the bug and then wrote some more
contracts and proved that the function
was correct so with that I come back to
my takeaways the contracts are it's a
contract sorry system that filled the
gaps that are left by any type system
and allows us to give a really fine
grained and detailed specification about
what it means to be a correct input to
our functions and interfaces contracts
are great because they make tests way
more awesome than they would otherwise
be contracts are a way of really force
multiplying the testing that we would
already be doing and beyond testing we
can use contracts as a scaffold for
writing documentation that's visible to
programmers but that also is a scaffold
that you know undergraduates and theorem
provers can use to think about what it
means for a program to be correct this
is a web page with more information and
links about the things that I wasn't
able to talk about and at ulta so if
you're interested in learning more about
what I do as an independent computer
science educator and curriculum designer
or you're interested in learning more
about C naught or Tim sort or the Java
modeling language then I encourage you
to go there for more information and I
really appreciate you all for attending
today thank you
you